Tonight, disgraced crypto entrepreneur Sam Bankman-Fried,...
...released from federal custody, wearing an ankle monitor...
...to await trial on fraud charges...
...that prosecutors called a crime of epic proportions,...
...alleging 8 billion dollars of customer funds missing.
He is indicted on eight counts that could send him to prison for life.
Bankman-Fried posted a 250-million-dollar bond co-signed by his parents...
...and secured by their home in Northern California,...
...where SBF will be under house arrest.
Prosecutors called it the largest ever pretrial bond they were aware of.
In court, the former FTX CEO, only heard saying, "Yes, I do"...
...when the judge asked if he understood the consequences...
...of not following the rules:...
...a warrant for his arrest.
Prosecutors said Bankman-Fried's decision not to fight extradition...
...and to return to the U.S. from the Bahamas where he lives,...
...factored into their decision to offer him bail.
Overnight, investigators turning up the pressure,...
...announcing two top business partners...
...agreed to plead guilty to multiple fraud charges...
...and cooperate with the investigation.
Bankman-Fried has not yet entered a plea.
Once he leaves New York,...
...the judge restricted any further travel to Northern California...
...and set his next court date for January 3rd.